morning so we're gonna start today with
Ben's all right so so this talk will be
about lower bounds for formulas so in
general I'll be talking about de Morgan
formulas so and or not formulas and
special subclasses pc0 and monotone so
okay as we all know proving formula
super polynomial formula size lower
bound for explicit function is one of
the major frontiers and complexity so
the strongest lower bounds we know
currently are almost cubic so so the
class of language is computable by
polynomial size formulas is known as MC
one so it sits here in this hierarchy of
classes so we have our small classes
here maybe for you to call medium
classes and our large classes so the
question is where should we be looking
for lower bounds if our goal is to prove
a super polynomial formula size lower
bound what kind of problem should we
focus on well what very natural approach
is to look at first try to prove lower
bounds for the very hardest problems and
I guess recently there's been success in
this mode starting with this line of
work of Ryan separating a cc0 from an X
but if we look at some of the classic
error lower bounds for these very small
classes what we can observe is that
their lower bounds typically
average-case lower bounds for the what
you could call the easiest hard problem
so techniques we had for a c0 lower
bounds naturally apply to the parody
function which is which you would like
here and even the nearly cubic formula
size lower bounds of our andreas
function which in fact has has a cubic
formula size and I think when we're
looking at average-case techniques in
the probabilistic method there's a good
reason for this we we we want to have
some handle on the problem and naturally
problems of lower complexity we could
expect to develop techniques to say
something about so our goal is lower
bounds for NC 1
we want to look for the easiest hard
problem that was outside of that class
and so I'll propose that the average
case k cycle problem or equivalently the
distance KSD connectivity problem would
be a good candidate for the easiest hard
problem that's outside of NC one okay
and so throughout this talk you can
think of k as being some large constant
or some barely super constant function
so let me talk a bit about this average
case k cycle problem so i'll be
considering a version of the problem on
layered graphs so here I have the the K
cycle graph okay so I'm identifying that
the two endpoints here and we're going
to be considering as inputs graphs on on
K n vertices arranged in two layers and
we have edges in between consecutive
layers and the question is is is there a
case cycle of going going across like
this that starts and ends at the same
vertex okay so this is the the K cycle
problem and this is equivalent to well
it's almost identical to the iterated
boolean matrix multiplication problem
and it's also equivalent to this
distance KSD connectivity problem so in
the average case version of the problem
will be considering an input which is a
random layered graph with independent
edge probabilities that are chosen
around you know 1 over n ok so we can
fix this edge probability so that the
probability of K cycle is exactly 1/2
let's say so this is like a layer there
- ranee graph ok and this is a about the
simplest kind of random graph well it's
a quite a simple random graph it has
constant average degree for example
alternative distribution which which the
same intuitions hold would be K random
permutations everything I'll say would
apply to either of these distributions
except for the lower bounds in the
monotone settings where we'd have a
difference so to understand this this
problem in the average case version let
me first go through the upper bounds for
this
for this problem and here there's a
difference I want to point out between
between the worst case and average case
versions so so the formula size in the
average case we actually get something a
little better I'll explain why and when
I claim that average case version is in
is in deterministic log space so we
actually have because this is constant
average degree we can do it simply in
log space whereas we'd have an NL upper
bound in the worst case setting moreover
you can implement these upper bounds by
monotone ac0 formulas and this upper
bound could be implemented by monotone
and switching networks of just
polynomial size so the the path set
framework that I'll try to say something
about is giving a lower bound for the
average case K cycle problem for both AC
0 formulas and also for unbounded depth
monotone formulas in the in the regime
of small K to mention so in the worst
case setting in the minuto models we
know no lower bounds of this form for
monotone formulas in the classic work of
cart where it Kherson and very nice for
attention giving these bounds for
monotone switching networks and the work
recent work of robert for monotone
spanned programs we have lower bounds
for the worst case complexity and the
point out these two lower bounds simply
couldn't apply for the average case
version of the problem since it has
polynomial sighs monotone switching at
first okay and the the ambitious goal of
this this this line of research would be
to extend the framework to get lower
bounds for general DeMorgan formulas so
right so let's build some intuition by
first look at the upper bounds so the
classic upper bound giving the best
formulas for this problem would be the
recursive doubling algorithm the ideas
were we're actually going to find
compute the set of all well we want to
determine whether it is a path between
every pair from the left and the right
and to do this recursively you would
find all the information of
whether it is path between every vertex
on the left and in the middle similarly
for the middle to the right and then you
merge the result of these sub
computations so this is computing a
boolean matrix product and if you work
out - if you implement this by formulas
you'd get something which is n to the
log K sighs solving this case cycle in
fact on all instances so this would be a
worst case algorithm right so this is
this is a also the idea behind savages
ok good so so we can actually do
something better in the average case and
I'm going to present this as a way of
introducing and motivating path sense so
so to recall we're looking at a random
layer graph with independent edge
probability around 1 over N and let me
call this gamma just to refer to this
random graph the random incident will be
gamma ok and here's the idea so if we
look at any square root n vertices on
the left and any square root n vertices
on the right then on average gamma would
contain just constant many paths which
start which start here and end here ok
with very high probability so the idea
is imagine we have formulas we're gonna
look at the left half here and root n
vertices here root n vertices here and
okay on average there's just constant
many paths and imagine we have formulas
which are spitting out the value of this
path this path so we have maybe you know
order login formulas which which you
know whose whose output simply
explicitly says what these paths are and
if we do this also for the for the right
here then we can we can merge the
results of these sub computations to see
whether the the constant many paths here
line up correctly with the paths here to
form a path going all the way across ok
and if we you know most of the time this
won't happen if we if we you know look
at login blocks of login vertices in the
middle
then we'd expect to see one path going
all the way across through through one
of these I'm sorry Rudin if I say it if
I said log and I mean rude and yeah
thank you okay so so this so if you
implement the formulas this way you'd
get root n to the log K sighs formulas
for the average case version of the
problem this is where this is where we
get something better in the average case
okay so I want to use this average case
algorithm to motivate path sets and what
I'll call path set formulas okay and you
can you can think of these as that may
be a class of algorithms which operate
on a similar principle to this one so so
a path set is so we're going to be
considering a sub graph of the of the K
cycle okay so denote it by G and then a
G path set is going to be a set P of
embeddings of G okay so by which I mean
an embedding of G you just map each
vertex of G to one of the vertices in
the in the cloud below it this describes
embedding of G here so P is a set of
those and we're not going to be
considering all sets but only sets which
are small in some sense so subject to
some density constraints and these
density constraints are going to
guarantee that for this random graph
gamma that it contains just constant
many that gamma contains constant many
of these embeddings with high
probability yes
P is fixed in advance yeah do you want
it's at least a constant of both at most
at most a constant and not only an
expectation but this is going to ensure
that you know the probability that gamma
contains say in to the epsilon elements
is going to be exponential
they small this one this is what the
definition is gonna guarantee so let me
just say what are the what are the
density constraints I should say these
definitions aren't right it's not
terribly important what the exact
definitions are just to give you but
it's easy enough the state so so if G is
just a path we simply require that the
density is at most one over N so for
example this if we have you know all
paths like this that start and end and
some fixed set of root and vertices this
has density 1 over n another example
which would be a non rectangular path
that would be I could take all
embeddings ABC where the sum of them is
0 mod n so if if your G has to is the
disjoint union of two paths then we get
three density constraints so we require
that the overall density is at most one
over N squared and we require that for
every way you could fix this
embedding x1 then the conditional
density over here would be at most one
over N and similarly if you fix density
would be just the the fraction of
embeddings which which are in P so so so
in this case it would just be the size
of P over N cubed okay and finally in
the case where G is the entire case
cycle there's no density constraints in
particular we have the complete K cycle
path set so the set of all K cycles okay
and this is going to be the object that
we're trying to build in this passive
framework okay and so we're going to be
looking at ways of constructing path
sets and we have two operations we can
form a union of two path sets so long is
that the the Union satisfies the
required density constraints and the
other operation is a join operation if I
have a G path set P and an H path set Q
the join is a G Union H path set this is
the definition but just as a picture for
every for every element of P and element
of Q which which coincide on the common
vert
CAES than the union of those two paths
would be an element of the join so this
so we have these two operations and if
you want to think of these paths that's
algorithmically so if I have an
algorithm which is given gamma tells you
the path the elements of P that are in
gamma and similarly I have an algorithm
which given gamma says the elements of Q
which are in gamma then you know we
could form one for the join since
they're just constant many you've just
sort of emerged the results when you say
whenever identity constraints are
satisfied with meaning on the Union on
the Union the joy it's automatic
actually but yes so you should think of
join as a hybrid of the product and the
intersections if if G and H are disjoint
this is the product if if G equals H
this is the intersection
yeah I think you said it but so we try
to construct this but yeah right so
we're trying to construct it so I'll say
let me say a bit more about it yeah I
think this is the upper bound right as
the type of we're going to think of this
constructions of paths as is a certain
type of formula that we want to prove a
lower bound for right so a path set
formula will be this is this is a bit
informal definition but so we'll think
of a formula where the input so the
leaves are labeled by the atomic path
set so just uh where G is a single edge
and P is a single is a singleton and
then we have Union and join gates again
subject to these density constraints so
you know maybe all the elements of this
formula are typed by some sub graph of
the K cycle and these gates so the
objective what we're trying to compute
with these paths that formulas is to
construct the complete K cycle path set
so the set of all K cycles or some dense
subset you are applying the
approximation method to the holiday
season know the dance to dance
things know it's actually different just
a just a when G and P are single terms
yeah so I don't wanna get too caught up
in definition but I sort of give a sense
the takeaway should be this is this is
some model of computing objects which
are some sense simpler than boolean
functions and also correspond in some
sense to average case algorithms so this
this average case recursive doubling
algorithm that I showed is giving an end
to the 1/2 log K upper bound on
the path set formula size of the
complete case cycle path set but in the
in the setting there are actually other
sort of surprising algorithms that are
also reasonably efficient so if all of
your joins are of graphs G and H of this
format overlap like this you can
actually get a lower bound sorry an
upper bound of the form n to the natural
log of K so and so the main the main
lower bound here for this path set
formulas is that so path set formula is
computing a dense K cycle paths that
require size n to the some constant
times log ok yeah these are this is
unbounded depth yeah right so ok so a
lot goes into this lower bound I mean I
hope I can say something about it but so
I'm gonna we're gonna the idea of this
passed that technique is to is to reduce
AC 0 and monotone formulas and hopefully
other kinds of formulas to this lower
bound so let me so to say this again if
if fee isn't forming which is either AC
0 or monotone and let's assume it solves
the average case case cycle problem the
idea of the technique is to convert fee
to a path set formula which is computing
a dense K cycle path set and then we can
appeal to this lower bound on the last
slide to get our lower bound of entropy
Omega launch a high-level right I'm
gonna in just two minutes go through and
just sort of illustrate what I mean by
this in the case where like fee is both
a c0 and monotone in fact let me even
skip the definition of what this is so
here we have some some formula and the
idea is we want to for every perfect
gate in this formula and every subgraph
of the K cycle g we want to consider
some path set some g paths that
associated so what this is is it's the
set of I mean this is the set of min
terms of of this shape
so just just so you can see how this
relates to this notion of path set
formulas so at the at the orders of the
formula you can see the minterms of an
or of the G shape them in terms of F or
G is contained in the Union here in the
case of I thought I had an and and slide
so for the and you get something in
terms of Union of joins and then at the
inputs you have atomic either empty or
atomic path sets and to get a lower
bound for for monotonic C 0 formulas it
would be enough to consider the random
graph here and to view this as a
restriction so apply apply this monotone
restriction to all gates in the formula
so I'll denote that by this FA Union
Gama and then you have these these
relations also hold under the
restrictions so just to take away here
is that ok we have a bunch of of these
path sets and we can see somehow that
they're being constructed by unions and
joints and then the key lemma which one
could show in the case where this
formula was a monotone AC 0 formula you
could show that under this random
restriction gamma all all of these these
sets would in fact be past that so it
satisfied these density constraints with
extremely high probabilities you could
take a union bound so this is sort of
impression it's thick but just to show
you how so you can see how how a boolean
formula induces a path set formula right
and then finally if you assume that this
formula solves the average case K cycle
problem then if you're looking at the
sort of top path set here so the the
case this case cycle paths that at the
output under a restriction then this
would be computing a dense K cycle path
set with some constant probability so
this is just appeal to the lower bound
so this is yeah this is very you know
and wavy but just to show you how the
how the technique looks like
in particular what this shows is that in
monotone are AC zero formula every game
has a shape after the restriction no so
this so right so this this is there are
a lot of complications because we have
for every gate it's not we don't
associated with a single type you know
for V for every graph G we get a path
set somehow out of that you have to
extract a shape you know maybe I'll say
something about it
in a bit right so the idea is that sort
of generalizing the results we have in
both the AC zero and monotone setting so
we can sort of apply this path that
lower bound to a DeMorgan formula
whenever all sub formulas have load G
sub graph sensitivity in some sense okay
at a random gamma so in and you know if
our formula is merely AC zero or
monotone then we required a different
way of defining these path sets we're
not just looking at min terms we're
looking at more complicated definition
here but you know and for the hope is
that for general DeMorgan formulas that
well certainly I think what's needed
here is sort of a top-down definition of
these path sets so in these cases you
can define the path that's just in terms
of the boolean function here but maybe
when one needs a top-down definition to
get for any hope of this working for
general DeMorgan formulas let me not say
right so what I mean by low G subgraph
sensitivity is gonna be a bit hazy here
but just to say something in them in the
monotone setting you know we have our
random game on we want to say is it sort
of sensitive at this particular
embedding and in the monotone lower
bound we're looking at sort of no adding
random noise which consists of some less
than root and random paths and somehow
the key point here is that this random
noise lives inside the if you add this
random noise to the gamma then the total
variation distance doesn't change much
and that's how we're able to get a
average case lower bounds so yeah let me
briefly say something about how how this
paths that formula lower bound is Prue
so this was this is a lower bound for
path set formulas and right so the key
to proving this lower bound is to look
at a sort of a form of passive formulas
where we restrict the type of joins or
we fix the pattern of joins so I'll call
a join tree is just a binary tree where
the Leafs are labeled by the the leaves
of the sorry the leaves are labeled by
the edges of the K cycle and every edge
appearing at least once so this would be
the recursive doubling pattern here okay
so where can we construct each segment
here is a union like this and with
respect to these join trees we get this
n to the one half log K upper bound so
this is maximally overlapping join tree
which I mentioned before this gives a
construction of n to the natural log K
upper bound I'll say something in a
minute and you could also look at a very
skewed joint trees like this and in some
sense this is going to correspond to
constant depth formulas for very small
depth for depths below K and so
something which I was able to show
recently is if you have a if you have
joint right so okay using using as some
generalization of these patterns you can
get sort of the optimal tight upper
bounds for a C's ya the upper bounds for
a C zero forms with depth to D you can
witness with join trees at this form
okay so the the way that we bound paths
that formula sizes via this notion of
path set complexity with respect to
fixed join trees all right don't don't
worry about understanding the definition
just the the point is so this this is
some complexity measure with respect to
any join tree over some graph of the K
cycle and any path set over that graph
and you can define as appointment
maximal function satisfying certain
inequalities what I want to highlight
here is that with respect this is sub
additive with respect to unions but it's
a we just take the maximum
respect to joins so the the sort of main
lower bound what everything boils down
to is proving a lower bound for every
join tree for the K cycle we prove a
lower bound on the path set complexity
with respect to that join tree in terms
of the density of P right I wanted it
point out there's only in the original
paper this constant here was 1/6 and
yeah I in anonymous referee sort of
tighten the analysis and should improve
this constant I was very impressed if
you don't know who you are but if you're
in the audience I wanted to take this
opportunity to thank you okay and just
to mention so there there are many
special cases of this lower bound which
make the problem much easier than the
general case so one one example being if
alphas read one so each edge of the case
cycle appears only once as a leaf you
can actually prove the completely tight
lower bound using essentially just
kosher Schwartz so something which I
showed recently was if if your alpha has
left depth D okay which is less than log
K so every branch in the in the in the
joint tree goes left at most D times
then you can you get this improved
improved lower bound I was gonna say I'm
gonna skip this part but just I was
gonna say where this comes from it's
it's it's some interesting purely
combinatorial problem about about join
trees I'm just gonna skip this in the
interest of time so I can mention some
next steps in this in this line of
research right so as I said the goal is
to try to apply this technique more
generally to Morgan formulas but there's
there's even even in the AC zero in
monotone settings there's some ways that
the technique I feel should be sharpened
before one attempts to to generalize it
further so right so one thing which so
we have this lower bound for bounded
depth patterns here okay in the past
that complexity world but I don't yet
know how to get to translate this to a
lower bound for AC zero formulas with
small depth okay so proving this would
be the sharpening you know giving a
tight version of this path that
trade-off for ec0 circuits for the
worst-case version of the case cycle
problem due to Jen she can eat or rocco
and the yang and just to point out so we
have this lower bound of n to the Omega
log K this hold up to very large depths
okay so unbounded and K up to nearly
login so this is something which one
should be able to get out of the
technique when the depth is very small
okay so here to highlight the so there's
an asymmetry and the definition in the
definition of the paths of complexity
were or gates this is this is a additive
for n gates we have a maximum here
and this suggests that we should be able
to prove a symmetric lower bounds for
for monotone formulas okay so this is
this is the the the join tree which
which is it has alpha on this side and
bait on this side yes so if you look at
the worst case monotone formula lower
bounds for K cycle Parchman witness and
they naturally are asymmetric if you
want to think of the KW games it says
that either the the player holding the k
cycle has to communicate log K log n
bits or the other player has to
communicate you know and to the epsilon
bits and I think one should be able to
show the same thing in the average case
setting say for monotone formulas even
for AC zero formulas I believe this
should be true and I think the passage
techniques should be able to show this
but somehow yeah this this corresponds
between and and or gates and the boolean
formulas not not exact so it's another
natural next step we try to apply this
technique to other classes so to AC zero
formulas with parity gates another
setting would be to multi linear
arithmetic formulas computing the
iterated matrix multiplication so this
arithmetic I was a great version of the
of the K cycle problem here here
recently so there are some some nice
lower bounds of the Shrikant than other
in the case where n equals 2 and also on
the bounded depth setting but this is
maybe another good case and I believe
also because the asymmetric nature of
ands and ORS that that the paths that
should be giving a lower bound and for
monitor comparator circuits but this is
another challenge yes so also it would
be interesting to improve this to the
optimal constant saying but maybe more
generally so one can view this as this
lower bound as in the form n to some
parameter depending only on the case
cycle and one could even generalize this
this whole approach from the K cycle to
arbitrary kind of fixed pattern graph H
and ask about the formula complexity of
average case each sub graph isomorphism
and right if you want to view this as a
sort of lifting theorem from some
parameter of the graph H so in some
recent work with
konnichi Cora by Asha we tied this
parameter to tree with polynomial e but
that's like tree depth but right be
interesting to know understand this
graph trim it are better and then the
final thing I wanted to mention is so
this whole technique is really quite
narrowly tailored to the to the this
average case K cycle problem so we so
you know one of the results is that
average case K cycle problem is hard for
monotone nc1 it's not in monotone nc1 I
don't know how to apply this technique
to show that even the K clique problem
is in the average case is not in
monotone nc1 somehow we're the you know
the average case distributions for K
cycle are much simpler we can say things
about these that I don't know how to say
about just GNP for 4k clicks right okay
thanks
[Applause]
every gate in the circuit in the
deductions lower let's say for monitor
nicely zero to the top set formula here
will it be virtually associated with one
type of many types yeah yeah so the the
right okay so here's just a simplest
case of when the phone is both monotone
na C's here then we only have to look at
these midterms and the four ORS we have
no problem in some sense so the
complexity here is in this and gates
what you all you can say is that every
min term of F and G is the union of a
min term of F and the union of them in
terms of G so we get an expression like
this we have we have to take the Union
over all ways that G can be formed as
the union of two sets and then we're
taking the joins of these relations the
most yeah collection and then to get the
lower bound in terms of in terms of join
trees what one does is you you look at
the top you have this dense path set at
the top and you want to you want to look
at how each min term there was
constructed and that gives a sort of
joint tree they've been sort of
partition that's said in to join trees
so when I said that all these techniques
work for small K we're paying a factor
of 2 to the 2 to the K and a lower bound
so that that factor of 2 to the to the
cake comes out of the density at the top
because they're just picking one of
we're looking at you know the most
frequent join tree and then we really
exploit the structure of these joint
trees in the lower bound so this this
paths that complexity measure
yeah I mean I entirely skip hat so the
combinatorial main theorem is is is this
lower bound yeah I mean I've never had
time to say any any kind of details
about this but it's it's a you know it's
you you really study this past a
complexity measure in terms of joint
trees and you show that it has some nice
properties it's monotone under motion of
projections onto subjoin trees and
there's a notion of there's another
operation on things you say structural
things you show about this that allows
you to to prove this well if I summarize
your long answer is that you you take
the general Morrison circuit you'll get
for me a passage formula and then you
take only the most popular
so this is a monotone I mean because the
process complex is a more compact oh yes
it is
alright thanks again
[Applause]